die intensivstation werden immer voller
und die lage bleibt eben das dramatisch
deshalb greift auch weiterhin die
operation kleeblatt intensiv patienten
die in den krankenhäusern vor ort einen
behandlungsplatz bekommen werden von der
luftwaffe zu freien intensivbetten
geflogen und heute steht eine weitere
verlegung von corona patienten an in
dresden landet nämlich am vormittag das
flugzeug der luftwaffe vor ort ist unser
reporter michael deutsch mann mit dem
wir jetzt auch sprechen wollen guten
morgen michael
guten morgen ich erzähle einmal wie
läuft der einsatz heute ab was ist
geplant
also wir erwarten hier den medien weg
airbus der luftwaffe gegen 10 uhr 30 der
kommt vom flughafen köln bonn wo er
normalerweise stationiert ist und soll
hier etwa sechs patienten aus den
sächsischen krankenhäusern
aufnehmen das ist also eine fliegende
intensivstation das sind auch schwer
erkrankte an krebs erkrankte patienten
wie man uns gesagt hat die alle beatmet
werden müssen dieser airbus ist eine
fliegende intensivstation die leute
werden also mit einem speziellen
rettungswagen hier zum flughafen
gebracht hier auf rollfeld und werden
dann direkt in den airbus verlegt dort
weiter beatmet weiter
intensivmedizinisch behandelt das ganze
läuft zwischen 10 30 und 14 uhr so
zumindest der plan und um 14 uhr soll
der airbus dann richtung köln wieder
abheben und soll die patienten die sechs
hier aus den sächsischen krankenhäusern
auf krankenhäuser in nordrhein westfalen
unter einem münster/osnabrück
beziehungsweise auch in köln verlegen
während du gesprochen also sehen wir die
bilder auch aus dem inneren dieses
airbus dieser fliegenden intensivstation
wie du gesagt hast wie ist denn aktuell
die situation in sachsen überhaupt so
dass das jetzt nötig ist
die lage ist immer noch sehr ernst und
wenig erfreulich wir haben eine
krankenhaus auslastung noch mal
nachgeschaut und nachgefragt von im
moment 96 prozent auf den
intensivstationen da ist also kaum noch
luft die erzgebirger kliniken im
landkreis erzgebirge meldeten am
wochenende das ist keine intensivbetten
zum beispiel er gibt in dresden und
leipzig großen zentren ist noch ein
klein bisschen da aber man muss
natürlich damit rechnen angesichts der
infektionszahlen die hier extrem hoch
sind wir haben heute wieder über 9000
neue infektionen die das rkw für sachsen
vermerk dann internet von über 1200 also
angesichts dieser zahlen muss man damit
rechnen dass in 14 tagen zu den bis
jetzt über 500 patienten auf
intensivstationen nochmal 200 dazu
kommen das sagen uns hier die
krankenhaus koordinatorin da gibt es
eine vorschau tool was auch die
regierung im freistaat immer nutzt also
mit 200 intensivpatienten rechnet man
noch und mannschaft sozusagen versucht
sich jetzt ein puffer um hier die
medizinische katastrophe wie man uns
sagt zu verhindern ein bisschen licht am
horizont gibt es auch in sachsen die
zahlen bewegen sich im moment ein
bisschen seitwärts wir haben ja hier
seit einer reichlichen woche seit fast
zehn tagen so eine art yahoo clock darin
gehabt die regierung nennt das
wellenbrecher lockdown dh
diskotheken bars großveranstaltungen
veranstaltung an sich sind geschlossen
fußball spiele finden unter ausschluss
von zuschauern statt also das scheint
sich so ein bisschen auszuzahlen wir
haben die zahlen sind etwa vergleichbar
mit denen von vor einer woche diese
dynamik im anstieg ist abgebremst und
alle hoffen dass dieser trend jetzt
fortsetzen und sagen der peak erreicht
ist und die zahlen jetzt vielleicht
rückläufig sind das ist die große
hoffnung die alle verbinden um damit
auch diese katastrophe zu verhindern die
man fürchtet was wir vorhin gesagt haben
in 14 tagen damit den 200 zusätzlichen
intensivpatienten michaele du kommst im
land herum in sachsen gibt es
überdurchschnittlich viele menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen warum
ist das dort so
wenn man das wüsste dann wäre das
wahrscheinlich die eine million dollar
frage es ist eine mixtur glaube ich aus
vielen faktoren grundsätzlich ist es
wohl so dass die sachsen besonders start
skeptisch sind so kann man das
vielleicht ausdrücken man ist
grundsätzlich ein bisschen misstrauisch
bei allem was von oben kommt
man vertraut dem staat und der regierung
eher weniger anders als vielleicht in
den alten bundesländern und deswegen
wenn jemand von der regierung oder vom
freistaat sagt diese impfung ist gut
nimmt die macht das dann ist man da
vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger mit
vorbehalten es sind aber auch viele eher
rationale argumente oft zu hören die
gängigen verschwörungstheorien die
kennen wir alle das ist natürlich auch
eine minderheit die die diese theorien
oder diese dinge vertritt es ist wie
gesagt auch auf bequemlichkeit das
erlebt man auch im privaten umfeld dann
ja ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen ich
weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau
viele andere rätseln auch aber es ist
wie es ist und im moment ist zu
beobachten dass es da so ein bisschen
klein schwung gibt also was man von den
ganzen booster aktionen hört da sind
auch viele erstimpfungen dabei
inzwischen auch zwei impfungen gibt der
hoffnung dass einige vielleicht sogar
umdenken was die die ganze im verein
betrifft andererseits ist es
organisatorisch auch eine frage die neun
jahren noch luft nach oben hat also wir
haben ja auch diese schlangen wir haben
auch organisatorische probleme
heute zum beispiel startet heute in
dresden das impfzentrum neue das war zum
30 september geschlossen worden man hat
ja fast vier wochen gebraucht um das
wieder hochzufahren also das ist auch
von seiten der behörden etwas suboptimal
wie die ganze veranstaltung hier
gemanagt wird und dazu kommt dann alles
zusammen und bildet eine explosive
mischung und die sorgt dafür dass wir
hier mit infektionszahlen zwischen
1200 incident und
infektionszahlen bis zu 12.000 am tag in
der vergangenen woche zu tun und zu
leben haben vielen dank für deinen
einsatz und sobald das flugzeug der
luftwaffe dann in ungefähr einer stunde
weil die landet schalten wir natürlich
noch mal wieder zu dir zurück
so machen wir das